AND MERRY CHRISTMAS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE.
THE EDITOR OF THE CHRISTIAN POST
IS QUITTING BECAUSE ALL THE
PUBLICATION TOOK A STANCE AND
DEFENDED THE PRESIDENT TRUMP
AFTER ANOTHER CHRISTIAN MAGAZINE
CALLED FOR HIS REMOVAL.
>> I WARNED HIM, IF YOU GO DOWN
THIS ROAD, AND JOIN TEAM TRUMP
THEN THAT WILL DESTROY THE
REPUTATION OF THE CHRISTIAN POS
POST."
WAS TOLD THAT THIS IS THE
DIRECTION THEY WANT TO GO.
AT THAT POINT, YOU KNOW, WE
REACHED THE IMPASSE AND I REALLY
HAD NO OTHER CHOICE BUT TO LEAV
LEAVE.
>> Jason: HE HAD ANOTHER
CHOICE BUT JOINING ME NOW IS
RACHEL CAMPO DUFFY RATE OF
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND RACHEL,
WHEN HE SAW THIS AND YOU READ
ABOUT IT AND HEARD THIS,
GENTLEMEN'S COMMENTS, WHAT DID
YOU THINK?
>> I THOUGHT HE WAS JUST TOTALLY
OUT OF STEP WHERE EVANGELICALS
ARE.
EVANGELICALS ARE 77% APPROVAL
FOR DONALD TRUMP AND AMONG THE
77% THE MAJORITY OF THEM DON'T
JUST APPROVE OF DONALD TRUMP,
THEY STRONGLY APPROVE OF
DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S NOT THAT THEY LOVE
DONALD TRUMP OR THEY LOVE THE
PRESIDENT TWEETS AND HIS
COLORFUL PAST, THAT'S NOT IT AT
ALL.
THEY LOVE THE POLICY.
THEY REALIZE THAT HE IS THE BEST
AND MOST FEARLESS DEFENDER OF
ALL THE THINGS THAT THEY BELIEVE
AND WHETHER IT'S THEIR PRO-LIFE
DECISIONS, SCHOOL CHOICE, EVEN
CHRISTIAN PERSECUTION BOTH IN
THE UNITED STATES AND ABROAD.
OF HE STOPPED UP ON ALL THESE
DIFFERENT POSITIONS THAT HE'S
TAKEN AND CHRISTIANS AND
EVANGELICALS AND CONSERVATIVES
IN GENERAL REALLY LOVE.
THAT'S WHAT THE PUBLICATION IS
DEFENDING.
NOT DONALD TRUMP, BUT THE
POLICY.
>> Jason: REALLY, AT THE HEART
OF THIS AND I UNDERSTAND THE
STORY, THE POSITION ON
IMPEACHMENT AND HOW CLEAR IT WAS
OR UNCLEAR, SOME PEOPLE WANT TO
SEE THE PLAYERS EVENT IMPEACHED
AND OTHERS DID NOT WANT TO SEE
HIM IMPEACHED.
I RESPECT THE RIGHT OF RELIGION
TO BE ABLE TO >> AND TAKE
POSITIONS ON THIS.
IT IS NOT SIMPLY HE'S DOING
HERE?
IS THIS A BREACH TOO FAR.
IF HE'S PUTTING HIS MONEY WHERE
HIS MOTHER'S
AND QUITTING, SAYING I CAN DO
THIS ANYMORE.
>> IF THIS COMES OUT AS AN
OP-ED, HE WOULD ACCEPT THE
PUBLICATION AND PUBLISH IN THE
EDITORIAL AND SAYING OF THE
ENTIRE PUBLICATION.
AGAIN IT'S THE INFANT JELL-O
PUBLICATION AND THEY ARE
REFLECTING THE VIEWS OF SO MANY
EVANGELICALS.
reflecting the views of so many
MANY EVANGELICALS CONSERVATIVES
AND CATHOLICS AND PEOPLE OF
FAITH, PRESIDENT IS BEING
PERSECUTED PRIMARILY BECAUSE AND
I BELIEVE SO MUCH A BECAUSE OF
POLITICS IN AMERICA IS ABOUT
ABORTION.
IT'S ABOUT THE SUPREME COURT,
THE APPOINTED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
THIS IS WHAT I THINK IS
ANIMATING THE LEFT AND ANIMATING
THE IMPEACHMENT PROCESS.
IT'S VERY RUDE AND PEOPLE DON'T
TALK ABOUT THAT, THEY WANT TO
TALK ABOUT UKRAINE AND THEY WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE RUSSIA HOAX
AND ALL THESE OTHER THINGS.
AT THE ROOT OF SO MANY OF THE
AMERICAN POLICIES IS ABORTION.
THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT
EVANGELICALS DO HAVE A TAKEN AND
THEY ARE VERY PLEASED WITH THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE AN TERMS OF
NOMINATING JUDGES AND REALLY
SETTING UP THE SUPREME COURT TO
TAKE A VERY CONSTITUTIONAL
POSITIONS AND ALSO A POSITION OF
LIFE AND DEFENDING LIFE AT A
CONSTITUTIONAL LEVEL.
>> Jason: I DO WISH EVERYBODY
WOULD GO BACK AND HEAR WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID IN FRONT OF THE
YOU UNITED NATION AMONG THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND IMPACTFUL SPEECHES
ON RELIGIOUS LIBERTY.
IF NO MATTER WHERE YOU ARE IN
THE RELIGIOUS SPECTRUM, WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS DOING AND FOR THE U.N. IT'S A
GREAT SPEECH AND HE NEVER GOT
ENOUGH CREDIT AND I HOPE PEOPLE
CAN GO BACK AND WATCH IT.
IT RACHEL CAMPO DUFFY,